As we just said, EHR certification
specifies requirements for
commercial EHR systems.
This is a very important development,
because for
decades the grand challenge for
health IT here in the U.S.
has been interoperability, the ability
of hundreds of commercial EMR
products and tools to exchange and
meaningfully share data.
Even with universal adoption,
without some degree of interoperability,
we still wouldn't be able to coordinate
care among the many providers who care
for the same patients and
who may well have different EMR systems.
So the EHR certification
process supports,
among other things, a basic
interoperability standard or capability.
Systems must be able to record key
specified demographic and clinical data.
They must be able to provide tools
to measure and improve care quality.
And, of course,
they must protect the confidentiality,
integrity of the health
care data that they record.
We'll now look at each
of these in some detail.